liberal Sanctuary cities are so bad that
even migrants want out Asylum Seekers
say Chicago is so unpleasant that
they're heading down south for the
winter with some even fleeing back to
their home countries one Venezuelan
family told the Chicago Tribune that
after several months of homelessness
lack of jobs and limited access to
better education they realize quote the
American dream doesn't exist anymore
meanwhile migrants and NYC are straight
up rebelling against the new Tent City
in Brooklyn dozens of families arrived
at the housing side and immediately
wanted no part of it claiming it's too
far from jobs and schools New York
Governor Kathy hokel says the city has
no
choice we are at capacity we have 65,000
people being housed right now they have
been accommodated in many times hotel
rooms in New York City for long periods
of time that's not sustainable and so
the option is to say if you want to take
advantage of public support Ed housing
and shelter for now this is your option
all right Dan and maybe this is a genius
strategy yes liberal Mayors got together
and said you want to get migrants to
leave make our cities as unlivable as
possible and they're really good at it
they have a l they're succeeding Wow
have you seen the litter out there today
I mean who would have given these
migrants the false sense that it was so
easy to come to America and just
parachute right in and have everything
that you possibly need oh that would
have been during the 2020 election when
the Democrats promised uh free health
care yeah and also that you have the
problem of the coyotes who are telling
them yes it's going to be great
everything's going to be fine you might
even have people here family members
saying yeah just come it'll be great
guess what it's not so great I do find
it ging that people who are receiving
charity at a hotel they're asked to go
to another location they're like yeah no
we're good we're going back to the hotel
how is that allowed how is that an
option I don't understand that also
remember when KLA Harris and vice
president and Joe Biden said don't come
that was the extent of their message I
hope that Iran listens more to the don't
than the uh IM immigrants did they came
with an expectation of luxury and they
crumpled at the first cold snap it gets
real cold in Chicago yeah if they go
home I hope I wish them the best that
might be the best option but one of the
problems is is that when they get here
then Catholic Charities for example or
any of the NGO are taking money from the
government and they're sending them to
Texas right and then those Texas are
sending to Chicago then Chicago is
sending them back to Venezuela then
there's more and so it's like never
ending until somebody comes in and cuts
it off yeah you know Jessica we've been
told for forever that these are people
in Desperate situations they need to get
away but then they realize ah this ain't
so bad I'm going back or this ain't so
good so we were we knew that we were
being lied to that they were just coming
here for the freebies and the
work
I'm not sure about freebies for everyone
I think most people have an interest in
the work and I see it every day when I
ride on the subway and it was a cover
story of New York mag talking about the
women who are selling candy on the
trains carrying their kids around with
them they do want to work some of them
some of them of course not and I
remember um we talked about this a few
months ago and Dana you were commenting
that your parents were staying in a
hotel that you basically couldn't get up
to the door of because there were
migrants outside and I said that what
upsets me about this as someone who's
supportive of the notion of sanctuary
cities and wants people to get this
chance is they're making a mockery out
of people like me right who advocate for
them to be able to come here that's our
job everyone is doing it to me I am the
ultimate victim of all of this but I
think also what's happening is they're
looking at previous generations who came
who were able to get jobs here and a lot
of that was because there were much less
of them right it's just too many people
that are coming in there are jobs that
are available Americans are kind-hearted
people who want to employ folks who want
to work hard who want to go out and get
a Social Security number and pay taxes
but when there are hundreds of thousands
it's really hard to get that done and
this is on Joe Biden you said last week
that Brandon Johnson the mayor of
Chicago you know went down to the White
House and he didn't get near what he
asked for and this is a federal problem
that's becoming a state and local
problem and that's on the federal
government to make sure that there's
enough housing for this but there you
know migrants are also pushing homeless
people out of these shelters and getting
those opportunities and it needs to
start with the Biden Administration on
down to fix it there's no system judge
that's always been the case you know
what you we we talked in the in the
block before this about you know the the
mob people are coming in and and and
with these retailers and destroying
cases because this is like a mob did
they decide how they're going to handle
this what I'm trying to say is this the
United States is nothing more than a
global landing spot with benefits and
when when they come here for the
American dream they're not coming here
for the American dream the way your
father did or my mother and father did
or any of us at the table because only
2% of the 140,000 migrants in New York
City have even applied for a work permit
and it may be that there are so many of
them but that's Joe Biden's fault okay
these people come in for Asylum Asylum
is only when you have a credible fear of
being prosecuted in your home country
not if you're poor not because you think
the American dream that doesn't get you
here and let me just say this if these
people who have been taken out to his
designated location in Brooklyn don't
like it and they want to come back to
the uh Manhattan to the Roosevelt pay
your own way and if you want to go home
pay your own way and by the way maybe
you shouldn't be allowed to go home
until you pay us for what we paid for
your food your education your medication
your health care money for food and
everything else you know this isn't like
with the uh uh Louisiana Purchase you
know everybody came here because you
could get an acre of land for 4 cents or
with the California the gold rush I mean
there were 300,000 people who went to
California because they want to make
gold or the after the Civil War 40 acres
in a mule everybody gets one no this is
a competitive work market and if you
want to work you can you can achieve the
American dream but they don't want to
work you know uh Jesse if you are you
know come out against us you lack
compassion never been a problem for
never been a problem for me Greg or me
KLA Harris said these migrants were
coming because of climate change MH it
was too hot in Latin
America it gets to be 50 degrees and
they're like we're going back maybe
they're snowbirds Greg maybe they're
just summering in Chicago and they're
wintering in Venezuela right you know
Biden paid for their flights their buses
why not and the ones in New York I'm
with the judge you can't stay at a $500
a night Midtown hotel for free for a
year where we do your laundry and we
make your dinners and then we get a
place in Brooklyn and they don't want to
burrow yeah oh so sorry Brooklyn is not
good enough for you oh because it's too
far away from your work well really
because only 2% of you are applying for
work permits what work
is it too far away from the schools well
they you can learn about CRT and
Brooklyn too American people are very
generous but we also don't like when
people are ungrateful and we're feeling
that they're a little ungrateful Greg
and I don't like it you shouldn't like
it Jesse as a paragon of gratitude as a
you are very upset all right coming up
comma Harris says we should start
listening to the radical anti-israel
protesters interesting hey Sean Hannah
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else